china is conducting military maneuvers
in response to u.s house speaker nancy
pelosi's visit to taiwan
these are taking place in the skies and
waters around taiwan and are set to
expand to live fire drills from thursday
but they are being watched by countries
in the wider region foreign ministers of
southeast asian grouping of nations
asean are beginning a series of meetings
in cambodia to discuss current issues in
the region and it is already clear
tensions over taiwan
are set to figure in the talks
we hope that you know
concerned parties
do not take actions that may
deteriorate or escalate the tensions and
i don't think that the escalation of
tensions will
help them to solve the problems or you
know solve the uh differences
and i again uh emphasize the need you
know for all the concerned parties to
reaffirm you know the position to all of
these basic principles so that we can
make sure that you know taiwan street
will be a peaceful
part of this region and joining me now
from manila is richard hederia and he is
an author columnist and political
scientist and has written extensively
about china's relations with southeast
asian nations richard what do you see is
the wider impact of nancy pelosi's
taiwan visit on asean nations
well definitely there's the element of
geography right so if you're in the
philippines taiwan is just across the
luzon strait so if anything happens
there it will have a direct impact on
countries like the philippines there's
also the the aspect of south china sea
as you may know south china embraces
huge parts of taiwan and it's also where
a number of southeast asian countries
have claims and we have seen based on
recent reports that china
one of its retaliatory measures is to
conduct live fire
exercises across south china sea
following the visit of nancy pelosi uh
to taiwan the other thing of course is
the fact that taiwan and china both have
very good economic relationship with
many countries in the region so even
though majority of southeast asian
countries have a one china policy
meaning diplomatically they only
recognize beijing as a true
representative of greater china but they
have also very robust economic
investment ties with taiwan so that's
why this is very complicated for a lot
of us in the region
which is why asean nations have
generally been reluctant haven't they to
pick sides between the us and china when
it comes to their rivalry in the pacific
but do you think they are slowly being
pushed into the direction of picking one
well not picking a side is a picking
is a choice in itself right so
definitely there are countries in
southeast asia which will be
fence sitters uh forever they'll try to
do that but at the same time let's not
forget the philippines thailand are u.s
treaty allies so in an event of conflict
if god forbid it reaches that point you
know bases in the philippines in
thailand potentially could be used by
american forces by japanese forces by
australian forces in an event of
contingency and then you have other
countries like singapore for instance or
even indonesia which are
non-aligned in terms of their formal
diplomatic predisposition but especially
in the case of singapore it has emerged
as a vital vital de facto ally of the
united states so i mean the joke is that
you know countries like the philippines
are allies that don't act like allies
while you know countries like singapore
are not allies but they act like allies
right so this is also the situation we
have it's much more complicated than
people being prevaricating but it's more
also a question of new alignments and
dynamic realignments that are happening
in the region
given all of that would it would
southeast asian nations let's just say
asean would it have been uh better
placed if this visit
didn't go ahead would that have been the
preferred option for asean nations
well i'm sure even inside taiwan and as
in as much insight in washington dc we
have a lot of people have raised their
eyebrows and have been asking okay i
mean we appreciate the symbolism of this
but if china responds in an aggressive
way i mean who are we gonna fault here
right i mean you could say that maybe
the u.s was the one who provoked china
while others would say let's also see
what china will do because if china
shows restraint and so far they have
shown a degree of respect restraint that
that also says something about rising
china and what kind of superpower it's
going to be in the coming decades now as
far as southeast asian countries are
concerned i mean their hope is that
china does not respond aggressively and
doesn't deploy aircraft carriers among
others and that the us will not escalate
it because we don't want to be caught in
in between the giants as much as
possible including for u.s treaty allies
like the philippines
uh do you think that there is a risk in
the in the next few weeks at least that
beijing might uh become a more assertive
when it comes to the territorial
disputes with southeast asian nations
such as the philippines indonesia and so
on and so forth
well
if you look at a technical textual
analysis the words that president xi
jinping has used or the statements that
have come from chinese uh you know
state-owned uh newspapers they don't
indicate the kind of aggressive response
or military action we saw from china
let's say compared to 1995 1996 the last
time we had a huge crisis military
crisis in the taiwan strait at the same
time we know that president xi jinping
also is facing economic slowdown at home
he'll have and political transition
later this year so i think that timing
militates against a much more
militaristic response but a kind of a
mid-range uh sh you know a shot across
the bow kind of response i think that is
something we're gonna see but the
problem though is
mistakes can happen you can have
unintended uh clashes and incidents and
that's something we're very worried
about at the same time as you correctly
pointed out the other question is what
is china going to do to south asian
countries is it going to pressure
southeast asian countries to distance
themselves from nancy pelosi's visit or
even say something critical about it so
those are the things we're going to
watch out so a lot is really uh gonna
depend on what china gonna do on both
military and diplomatic front in the
coming months and weeks
richard always a pleasure talking to you
we'll have to leave it there thanks so
much for joining us today richard
hiderian
you